on l'appelait le plus petit musée du
monde au départ il n'y avait que 5
tableau de courbet dans les salons de la
mairie d'ornans en septembre 1971 le
premier musée est inaugurée dans la
maison de famille de courbet six ans
plus tard l'institut courbet cède le
musée au département du doubs pendant 37
ans jean jacques vernier conservateur
bénévole de l'institut courbet va faire
de cette maison au coeur d'ornans un
musée à part entière j'ai vécu toute ma
jeunesse c'est toute mon enfance bercée
dans les souvenirs ma peinture est dans
les souvenirs des courbes et en 1991
l'origine du monde et même discrètement
exposé le temps d'un été en 2005 le
projet d'extension du musée courbet est
votée par le conseil général du doubs
avec la ferme de flageller source de la
loue c'est tout un territoire qui doit
être mise en valeur après un peu moins
de deux ans de travaux et une série de
polémiques avec l'institut courbet le
nouveau musée ouvre c'était il ya tout
juste dix ans au nom de la cour peut le
musée étoffe sa collection permanente et
resserre ses liens avec le musée d'orsay
d'avoir à nos côtés le musée d'orsay
c'est un atout supplémentaire pour nous
parce qu'ils ont évidemment un fonds
d'oeuvres très importants et ils ont
également un réseau considérable en 2013
neil 500 donateurs participe à
l'acquisition du chêne de flash est
quelque chose de très ému que leur part
ici je suis contente d'en posséder
métier
c'est aussi l'année de l'exposition
cours baissent des ânes le record de
fréquentation est battu près de 84 mille
visiteurs en un an
mieux que la saison ou reviendra à
l'origine du monde à ornans plus tard un
collectionneur montbéliarde et fera don
du veau et une autre souscription
permettra à juliette d'entrer dans les
collections du musée juliette la petite
soeur de courbet c'est elle qui la
première rêvait d'un musée pour exposer
l'oeuvre de son frère la boucle est
bouclée